nuevamente bienvenidos antes de que
veamos cómo calcular la altura a la que
llegó la pelota algo que sin duda
ustedes ya podrían calcular les voy a
enseñar una manera más intuitiva para
saber qué tan rápido lanzaron la pelota
la primera vez usamos esta ecuación para
calcular la velocidad
la diferencia en distancia que es igual
a la velocidad inicial por el tiempo más
la aceleración por el tiempo al cuadrado
entre 2
para mostrarles que esta ecuación en
realidad puede ser útil aunque en lo
personal a mí siempre se me olvidan las
fórmulas así que me ayuda mucho usar el
sentido común para inferir las
ecuaciones y esta ecuación fue inferida
usando el sentido común
bueno pensemos en el mismo problema pero
sin tomar en cuenta las ecuaciones aquí
la vamos a dejar nada más para
acordarnos que esta es la que usamos en
el vídeo anterior
pero ahora vamos a pensar qué es lo que
está ocurriendo
esto siempre es útil cuando se nos
olvidan las fórmulas en un examen
entonces cuando yo lanzo la pelota hacia
arriba vamos a dibujar la pelota que se
parezca una pelota de béisbol
la lanzó hacia arriba
y qué pasa bueno tiene una velocidad
inicial porque le estoy dando una fuerza
para lanzarla en el momento en el que la
lapso va a comenzar a desacelerar
desacelerarse ya que tengo la fuerza de
gravedad que me está jalando en el
sentido contrario hacia abajo tenemos
entonces que nuestra fuerza de gravedad
es igual a menos 10 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado y es menos porque es hacia
abajo entonces la pelota se va a ir
desacelerando
hasta que llegue a una velocidad igual a
cero
haciendo un diagrama del tiempo y la
distancia vamos a cambiar el color vamos
a hacer un diagrama aquí
tenemos en este eje lo que es la
distancia
y en este eje vamos a tener ellos
el tiempo
entonces vamos a tener que aquí lanzamos
la pelota va con mucha fuerza mucha
velocidad pero va desacelerando va
desacelerando hasta que llega un punto
en el que no se mueve y empieza a
acelerar en el sentido contrario oa
desacelerar hasta que cae al suelo
y bueno asumimos que no hay resistencia
del aire entonces la velocidad con la
que llega al suelo va a ser la misma
velocidad con la que se lanzó solo que
va a tener una dirección opuesta
aquí hay un par de cosas interesantes el
tiempo en el que la velocidad llega a
cero es decir en este momento en este
punto vamos a cambiarlo de color para
que se note mejor
en este punto en que la velocidad tiene
objeto llega a cero es decir se detiene
es el tiempo
si este es el tiempo que me tardo desde
que lance la pelota desde que la pelota
dejó mi mano hasta que cayó el suelo
este es el tiempo d
el tiempo en el que la pelota quedó
detenida durante un momento es de entre
si se fijan esta es una parábola esta
curva y podemos deducir su ubicación
usando esta fórmula anterior de la
diferencia la distancia y bueno a la
velocidad inicial por el tiempo más la
aceleración por el tiempo al cuadrado
entre 2 aquí recordamos que es tiempo al
cuadrado vamos a borrarlo
este es tiempo al cuadrado no tiempo
entonces voy a escribir el subíndice más
chiquito para que se note
entonces esta parábola abre hacia abajo
ya que este término es negativo por la
aceleración
lo que queremos saber es si conocemos el
tiempo te podemos decir que la mitad de
ese número bueno supongamos que el
tiempo en el que cayó la pelota el
tiempo t
es igual a 10 segundos
así que sabemos que tengo 10 segundos
desde que la pelota va al hombro mi mano
hasta que cayó al suelo
y también sabemos que el té entre 2
igual a 5 segundos
que a los 5 segundos la pelota se quedó
esencialmente quieta por un momento
justo antes de volver a acelerar pero
ahora hacia abajo como podemos ser el
hecho de que la pelota llega a una
velocidad igual a 0 en 5 segundos
bueno veamos que también tenemos otra
ecuación sencilla sabemos que la
diferencia en velocidad
es igual a la aceleración por el tiempo
y también tenemos que esta diferencia de
velocidad es la velocidad final menos la
velocidad inicial igual a la aceleración
por el tiempo
en la excitación cuál es la velocidad
final ya que no voy a recorrer todo el
camino hasta que la pelota cae al suelo
sino voy a llegar hasta la mitad del
tiempo y aquí la velocidad final es
cuando la pelota se detiene no va ni
hacia arriba ni hacia abajo entonces
finalmente nuestra velocidad final es
ser
entonces sustituimos aquí 0 menos
nuestra velocidad inicial
va a ser igual
a nuestra aceleración qué es
- 10 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
por el tiempo que en este caso nuestro
tiempo de interés este menos 2 perdón t
entre 2 aquí vamos a hacer una
distinción porque estamos usando la
misma literal o la misma letra para el
eje del tiempo y el tiempo en el que
termina nuestro decaer nuestra pelota
nos vamos a usar aquí te subíndice 0 y
la mitad de este tiempo va a ser te va a
ser t subíndice 0 entre 2
entonces aquí sustituimos
- 10 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
que es la aceleración por nuestro tiempo
que este subíndice 0 entre 2
y hacemos las operaciones
vamos primero a multiplicar por menos
uno de ambos lados de la ecuación
entonces nos queda velocidad inicial es
igual
el menos por el menos uno con el que lo
estoy multiplicando se anula 10 entre 2
me queda 5
metros por segundo al cuadrado por
tiempo cero subíndice cero
entonces esta resulta ser la misma
fórmula que obtuvimos en el vídeo
anterior
sólo que aquí lo hicimos de una manera
muy intuitiva y en el vídeo anterior
usamos la fórmula de la diferencia en
distancia igual a velocidad inicial por
el tiempo más la selección por el tiempo
el cuadrado
bueno y antes de calcular la distancia
vamos a hacer un poquito más de gráficas
voy a separar aquí el espacio para que
no se confundan vamos a hacer unas
gráficas para completar o tener un mayor
entendimiento de lo que está ocurriendo
y espero que de esta manera ustedes
tengan una mayor comprensión y a una
mayor comprensión ustedes verán que
nunca se les van a olvidar estos
conceptos vamos a graficar de nuevo
nuestra
a distancia con respecto al tiempo
entonces tengo aquí mi eje de la
distancia ustedes disculparán que esté
chueco
distancia
con respecto al tiempo
y aquí bueno quedamos que la lanzamos
veloz menos veloz llega un punto en que
se detiene y baja hacia el sentido
contrario
aquí es el tiempo cero y aquí a la mitad
justo cuando se queda quieta
es nuestro tiempo tercero entre 2
ahora vamos a graficar
lo que es la velocidad con respecto al
tiempo entonces tenemos aquí nuestro eje
de la velocidad
y nuestro eje
del tiempo
aquí iniciamos con una velocidad inicial
positiva que es con la que nosotros
estamos lanzando la pelota
y en este caso bueno lo voy a poner con
otro color
la velocidad va a decrementar sé de
manera constante
más o menos así una línea la velocidad
se decremento de manera constante a una
razón constante y esta razón es la
aceleración de la gravedad
entonces
vemos que en el tiempo bueno va
desacelerando llega un momento en que su
velocidad de 0 y esto en el tiempo es
cuando tenemos de 0 entre 2
y va acelerando pero ahora en el sentido
contrario hasta que en el tiempo de
cuando toca el suelo
su velocidad es exactamente la misma
velocidad que tenía al inicio pero en
sentido contrario hacia abajo y por eso
le ponemos el signo negativo
lo que tiene sentido porque cuando
tenemos el tiempo en este momento cuando
tenemos la velocidad de igual a cero en
el tiempo cero entre dos es el mismo en
el que está aquí está el punto en el que
se detiene la pelota cuando le lanzamos
entonces bueno la pelota inicio muy
rápido va desacelerando a esa una ración
constante y cuál va a ser la pendiente
de esta línea
bueno la pendiente es la aceleración
porque porque recordamos que la fórmula
es que la velocidad es va a ser igual a
la aceleración por el tiempo entonces la
aceleración es la que me va a dar la
pendiente o la inclinación de esta curva
entonces
si queremos graficar la aceleración con
respecto al tiempo vamos a usar otro
color
tenemos que es muy sencilla tenemos aquí
el eje de la aceleración
el eje del tiempo
y mi aceleración en este caso es
constante tenemos que la aceleración es
la de la gravedad a menos 10 metros por
segundo al cuadrado y siempre se
mantiene es una constante entonces va a
ser una línea recta
si conocen algo de cálculo ustedes
comprenderán que esta línea
pero aunque esta línea en la velocidad
es la derivada de esta curva de esta
parábola
y aún cuando no sepan de cálculo ustedes
comprenderán que esta constante de
aceleración que tenemos aquí en esta
gráfica
y va a ser la pendiente de nuestra línea
de velocidad
recordemos que la derivada es una manera
de conocer la pendiente o inclinación de
una curva en cualquier punto de ésta
así que bueno no se preocupen no es un
concepto complicado bueno nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo